betta butta butta para a bebop betta
butta butta
beep candy pop up the 50s we had the
best music the fifties they talked about
pure things do you up doo-wop they
talked about getting together they
talked about dancing Knicks right and
now it's all negative music today is all
about I'm gonna kill your temples with
my [ __ ] gun well what song is that I
don't know I know but like shredded but
you know and the but yeah she couldn't
when they were francium he's hipster
they have fancy mustaches they go out
into the desert and they go to trololo
challenge whatever Coachella and they
think they've hit on girls they give
them drugs purple pills purple pill
right and then they pass out in the dirt
a little jiggly jig and then they feel
great for a weekend but then boom they
have to go back to Best Buy they don't
work there they just they just wander
the halls
yeah I mean so you know I don't go to
the desert
I don't do Coachella you don't
jiggety-jig I don't jiggle jiggle
you know by wish I remember the old days
the 50s those were the good days
remember I had a dream to Ritchie Bamba
his brother Lou Diamond wait what's the
actor that plays lead I Morales bro yeah
yeah he was so hot yeah Esai Morales
played Richie Valens brother in the
movie lebombo and and I remember and he
was a cartoonist in it right yeah yeah
he played a cook and that he didn't make
it
and Richie Valens made it and he goes I
have a dream too Richie and he cried
yeah really touch who Diamond is part
Filipino uh a fourth oh that's it yeah
yeah Bobby was trying to tell me the
other day he was like yeah Koreans you
know we have the best UFC fighters like
who do you have and I was like ah Munoz
Robbie Lawler Johnny but you guys are
naming and my argument is this your
naming half-breeds
it's like when they say Rob
Schneider is Filipino he is full all
right
it's like 20 Thornburg the model he's
half Chinese but is he
no he's its own you creation hybrid so I
was asking what full-blooded we have
Philippine fully young who fights at one
Epsilon
he's a champion yeah we have a lot of
here's the one here's the argument you
got you made is is that you have the
best fighter in the world
Manny Pacquiao so you win there yeah
okay you win he finds every avenue to
like [ __ ] on my people no no here's the
thing and this is what I wanted to talk
about I forgot because I read a comment
on Instagram and it says does Bobby Lee
hate white people and I go I really it
broke my heart when I read it yeah
because I embraced them I love them
well I would be I would be nowhere
without them there are my comrades in
the war of life key word comrades my
equals you're not your bosses so now my
bosses know we're equals
okay I love your people the Philippines
no no I'm telling right now I really do
without you guys that would be nowhere
in life in fact I want to say that about
every race Mexicans we'd be nowhere
without you blacks no one without you
we're all one I'm a good guy and I know
when people say that I'm a good guy
out loud that means that they're not a
good guy but I'm just acknowledging the
fact that I'm aware of that
right so I am a good guy okay okay and
two years ago I hope the [ __ ] cross
the street Oh what would happen it was a
[ __ ] that's not a physically [ __ ]
that's
whatever did I help them yeah I carry
them across the street put me down put
me down
I gotta help you sir I'm a lawyer when
you do it yeah yeah yeah it was Peter
Dinklage I probably help you across the
street if I see ya I have little legs
too
yeah that's why I relate to them your
proportions are a little but I you know
I love the blind
okay the blind people are good I love
the Deaf they're good too I love oh I
love all people and when I see movies
with the horrific horrific things mm-hmm
like grenade babies in Vietnam movie I
don't know what those are the little
babies just you know they should to put
the Kong what do they call them good
call good call
you used to put little grenades is this
a valid historian they used to crawl in
your villages and blow them up or I see
that movies when I see in a movie I
think that's a figment of your
imagination it might be cuz that just
sounds awful training babies terroristic
and crawl no I don't believe that I
don't believe any well maybe they have
them in a carriage and they throw me I
don't know what it is I think you dream
[ __ ] about you know but if I do see that
if I did see that I would be broke
heartbroken um when I see like I know
you don't hit like this word you know
and I know you don't like the love word
face I don't know what the bird is for
their face I know you don't like this
word and if this is really from my heart
so I have to say it okay I [ __ ] hate
rape scenes in movies oh yeah I told him
he wasn't allowed to talk there about
anymore
like when I see a rape scene in a movie
I have to turn it off or fast forward he
has to pause so he cannot in his pants
yeah that's that's you know that right
there when you set that like that that's
really rude and it goes against my
spiritual you know being hmm you know
what I mean Gilbert no one's gonna
crucify you for Thought crime there's no
such thing I know but anyway I think
that white person is just that white
purposes said that does Bobbili wipe it
like both yes yes he does like white
people I love Allah
and hate you I love everyone
[Music]